good morning believe nation today's
message is believe in joy over to you
john travolta i was always a person with
a lot of confidence and I never took
very seriously any one making less of me
I think you learned by your failures and
you learn by your mistakes but you don't
take them to heart because as soon as
you do it takes the spirit out of you it
kind of you die a little bit look the
world is dark as just it's as bad as it
gets you look in the newspaper it's bad
news you look over your shoulder it's
bad news is if you want me to cry out
try right now for you because I can find
so much sadness in the world I can find
so much tragedy I can find so much
heartache that it will just be massive
okay now where's the joy where's the
spirit where's the fun that's the goal
to me so I've never understood why so
much is harped on the negative because
negative is easy dark is easy and doing
it artfully yes we must all do that but
I find it much more interesting to find
out where the joy is so during those
times I probably perceived negative but
I went for life I learned how to become
a jet pilot I traveled the world I
rubbed elbows with all sorts of people
and I learned what they were about and
it was feeding me you know now I had a
choice I could have believed that things
were finished things were over that life
is bad that life is not worth it why
don't we all die or something like that
it's just not not my nature you see so
my feeling was that you get through that
the best you can by living life fully
and using the spirit of other P
to feed you and you feed them and you
rise above it all that way I think this
is a really important message for
entrepreneurs I think to be a success as
an entrepreneur you have to you have to
be optimistic you have to choose joy
over negativity yes you can be paranoid
and the only the paranoid survive but
you have to feel like it's gonna work
out otherwise you get so lost down in
your hole that you never come out
entrepreneurs are the ones who make it
out being a successful entrepreneur is
one of the hardest things you have to do
in your life right that the failure
rates are crazy 85% 90% of new
businesses will fail and yet here we are
trying to do it trying to be the ones
who beat the odds and survive and build
something amazing we're on paper you
know the odds are against you you're
trying to do something new that's never
been done before
you're not educated for it you don't
know the capital for you know the
resources or connections or family for
it and here you are trying to do it
that's what entrepreneurs do and so you
have to choose joy you have to be
optimistic that it's gonna work out and
I think the thing that entrepreneurs are
best at is recognizing that when there
is some kind of crisis when there is
something really negative it's thinking
about how do I turn this into a positive
it's the example of when life hands you
lemons you make lemonade and you sell
the recipe for it - that's what I'm
entrepreneur does right life is gonna
hand you tons of lemons life is gonna
suck in a lot of ways you're gonna get
blow after blow after blow in your
business life and in your personal life
and if all you do is stay in your hole
you're never gonna create anything
amazing you have to look at that crisis
that most people would get lost in and
say life is terrible and just complain
right most people just complain when
something bad happens to them they just
complain when they and they blame
somebody else where the entrepreneur
grows from it builds from it sees the
opportunity in it gets stronger because
of it and they go off and build
something amazing
I think this is ingrained in a lot of
entrepreneurs but if it's not if it's
not you then I would encourage you to
think like if you're down in the hole
right now if you've just been given
successive blows ask yourself where is
the opportunity here how can I take what
just happened to me all of this stuff
that's really sucks and turn that into
something amazing
even just asking that question how do I
make this amazing how do I find the
opportunity instead of what you're
likely currently telling yourself why
does this always happen to me
when is it gonna get better right the
complaints change your questions to be
more optimistic and you'll get better
answers so the question they today is
I'm curious when was a time in your life
that you needed the most to believe in
joy tell me a story share it below leave
in the comments I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to and leta Torres from lead
grow develop calm and Lita thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
during one word it really really really
really means a lot to me so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot a vinspresso
hey guys it's a special bonus for this
video I'm gonna clued some extra clips
on choosing joy believing in happiness
that I hope will also inspire you I as
you know I was a bouncer for many years
I remember coming home one night after a
big fight run up to the kitchen I get
ice and I'm my hands swollen and then
just another day at work and I was
feeling like just bummed about the fact
that I was still doing this job after
all this time and I'm at that one moment
I was like
why are people what what's up why do
people have so much anger why do I have
to you know why is this my Bailey life
to suppress everybody's anger or check
everybody's anger that comes into the
giant 3,000 person nightclub mm-hmm and
my father it was so simple but my father
said you know then I've traveled around
the world I've been to India I've been
to Russia I've been to China I've been
all up in the south and all through
South America and I've realized
something I said what he said people by
and large are good people
sounded pretty simple and yet it meant
so much and if you look at my facebook
page if you look at the way that all
that positive energy I don't think
there's a page in the world in history
that harbours is much positive energy as
one would see on this Facebook page and
it's when you put out to and it's really
there right and I say that because I say
that because if you believe that in your
heart and not everybody watching this
can say that or is ready to say that or
it's comfortable with themselves enough
to say that but if you really believe in
your heart that people by and large are
good people it affects the way that you
address the world as you see post in and
post our I I address a world that in my
soul I feel is comprised of good people
mamas were just to be far at peace
within yourself because once you find a
peaceful for yourself that the energy
that you get usually is reflecting and
people you get the energy off the useful
and that's what I've been able to find
from the
you know on the negative energy side as
a young artist too a grown man that
projects positive in the peaceful music
but it still has the energy of a young
spirit so it's all within the same realm
but it's just finding yourself and being
able to be within yourself and have
peace so that way you can project peace
you know especially on the internet you
know you can get pulled into a whole lot
of negative energy I've done things
where I put pictures up and read
comments and then I'll say something
back and I end up arguing with somebody
on the internet that I don't even know
and I'm like you didn't pull me all out
of my skin so I was like it's just a
corner north you know your limitations
is born where you're going and let
people take you out of yo your frame
were you are never allowed nobody to
take me out the - take that I'm supposed
to be you know saying you never let them
see you sweat and never know who see me
you know deal with adversity whereas if
I can't deal with it so if you're going
to be successful in creating the life of
your dreams you'd have to believe that
you are capable of making it happen you
have to believe that you have the right
stuff and that you're able to pull it
off now whether you call it self esteem
self confidence or self assurance
it's a deep-seated belief that you have
what it takes the abilities you know
resources the talents and the skills to
create your desired results now
believing in yourself is simply an
attitude believing yourself is a choice
you have to choose to believe that you
can do anything you set your mind to
anything at all because in fact you can
it might help you to know that the
latest brain research now indicates with
enough positive self-talk and positive
visualization combined with proper
training coaching and practice anyone
can learn to do almost anything now I've
interviewed thousands of successful
people and almost every one of them has
told me I was not the most gifted or the
most talented person in my field but I
chose to believe that anything was
possible and because of that I studied I
practiced and I worked harder than the
others and that's how I got to where I
am
you know if Ruben Gonzalez a 20 year old
living in Texas hot Texas
can pick up the ludes which is a winter
sport and become an Olympic athlete if
Bill Gates who is a college dropout can
become a multi billionaire and Steven J
Connell who was a dyslexic student who
failed three grades in school can become
a best-selling author and a television
producer then you too can accomplish
anything if you'll simply believe it's
possible so make the decision right now
to believe that you create all of your
experiences because you do let's start
creating the ones you want by believing
you can sounds a little strange but
accepting this level of responsibility
is uniquely and inevitably empowering it
means you can do change and become
anything at all if you have this crazy
idea you must believe in it even if no
one else does so when I had the idea to
go to every country in the world that's
kind of what it felt like it felt like
this crazy idea it was like that just
sounds like totally ridiculous and
absurd but I couldn't stop thinking
about it and I realized that if I didn't
pursue it I would always regret it and
that that knowledge that fear of regret
kind of drove me to say yes and I talked
to lots of other people who used very
similar language there's a guy from
Portland Maine whose crazy idea was to
walk across America and he wasn't even
sure like how does that work how much
time does it take has anyone done this
before it was this crazy idea that
wouldn't leave him alone and so one
morning he left his home in Maine and he
started walking and seven and a half
months later he arrived in San Francisco
and I talked to him throughout the whole
journey I talked him in the beginning
and in the middle in the end and I asked
him you know what was the what were the
challenges like and how did that go and
he said he said something that stayed
with me for the rest of my journey he
said you know there were lots of
external challenges it was hard on the
body to get used to walking that much
lots of things went wrong there were
some emotional challenges as well he
just had a breakup and he was kind of
processing all of this he said but what
I realized about two weeks in once I
started complaining once I stopped
complaining and grumbling about the
whole thing he said I realized that my
task was pretty simple all I had to do
was walk essentially and if I did
nothing else if I got up every morning
and I made a little bit of progress then
eventually I would reach the goal
eventually I would arrive in San
Francisco and you know achieved that
that goal
reach that destination and it sounded
really simple but it's kind of stayed
with me for the you know the final two
years of my quest because that's how I
felt it was for me to all I had to do
was get to 193 countries and I had my
list of countries and I was making
progress and if I got stomach stuck
somewhere you know eventually I'd have
to overcome that challenge but I could
go and do some others first and I liked
the logical analytical progress of it
it's something that related to me so
just keep going you have to believe in
your dream even if no one else does